let's consider a two-dimensional motion
suppose we have something like
projectile motion and we have an object
moving
let's now describe how we can just
describe this motion with vectors so the
first thing we always want to do and
let's remind ourselves of the steps is
we want to choose a coordinate system
now what is the coordinate system
consist of it consists of an origin it
consists of two axes in this case we'll
identify these the positive direction
for each axis is plus X and plus y and
at every single point in space so if we
had any arbitrary point P here P let's
call this p1 we have a choice of unit
vectors I have one and J hat one now
what makes Cartesian coordinates unique
is that no matter what point we're at
the unit vectors are all the same so we
could erase all these indices for that
particular point and just have an
abstract set of unit vectors I hat and J
hat now normally what we'll do is we'll
just put those off to the side so in our
Cartesian coordinates we now want to
define the position vector and the
position vector is a vector from the
origin to where the object is so we'll
write that position vector we'll denote
it by R of T because as this object
moves along its trajectory that position
vector is changing and we'll write down
R of T in terms of two coordinate
functions X of T and Y of T and so our
vector position vector of the object R
of T is equal to X of T I hat plus y of
T J hat and one of our main goals is to
figure out what these position functions
are for the motion of objects so this is
how we describe an object in a Cartesian
coordinate system undergoing
two-dimensional motion what we want to
analyze next is what is the velocity of
that object